america has their fights on facebook
live in china and iran and everybody's
watching us saying look at these idiots
telling us exactly their marital issues
china gave us the virus the free world
right now is giving us the vaccine
the way you divide people is typically
you say see that group of folks over
there they're the ones that you're
supposed to be
afraid of and i'm going to protect you
israel invaded lebanon in 2006.
i was part of the contingent marines
that evacuated all the americans out of
the embassy there
countries that state court what they
stand for russia china india whatever
maybe they're like no this is what we're
all about you don't like it leave this
place versus america's like
oh you don't like it well let us change
for you i think you can't
understand the united states as it
exists today unless you understand the
american civil war
people are trying to cancel each other
destroy each other's livelihoods because
of a difference of agreement in the 60s
you had a counter-culture movement
the counterculture has become the
culture if you're a patriots fan you're
probably a republican
you know it's like becoming like my
seven-year-old
shouldn't be thinking about the politics
of his movies or his
tv ads or the united states has had to
figure out how to be the united states
and constantly reinvent itself before
but we're in one of those moments right
now and if we don't figure it out
guest today has a resume that can
probably land him a job anywhere but he
chose to be a writer and when you hear
about his resume going to say
this makes sense let me get right into
it so elliot akerman
uh is an american author but he's also
former white house fellow and marines
served five tours
of duty in iraq afghanistan where he
received the silver star
the bronze star for valor and a purple
heart with that being said my guest
today elliot acromer elliott how are you
good thanks so much for having me yes
it's good to have you on obviously look
you're on your sixth book and you
uh whatever you write does very well
new york times bestsellers and your
recent one that you wrote which is the
one i want to focus on is
a title uh 2034
a novel of the next world war which has
a lot to do i think china's involved
iran's involved it's fair to say it's
some
cyber security it's a different kind of
award than what we're used to but i'm
really curious to get into especially
with somebody who
chose to leave the military to want to
go and to write so if you don't mind
taking a moment for those who don't know
you eliot give us your background
uh to get a little bit of context there
and then we'll go into the book
yeah sure um well as you alluded to you
know i'm a former uh marine corps
officer
i came into the marine corps out of
college in
2003 which was the year we invaded iraq
so that was sort of an interesting year
to be a newly minted marine infantry
officer
uh i served in iraq i served uh
when hurricane katrina hit i served in
hurricane katrina
when israel invaded lebanon in 2006
uh i was part of the contingent marines
that evacuated all the americans at the
embassy there
then i went to special operations where
i served in and out of afghanistan
from 2008 to 2011
and then i did a year working at the
white house
um but i've always been a reader i'm
actually the son of a writer so i'd
always been around
other writers um so the you know the
idea of making that career transition
didn't seem as strange as it might sound
at face value
and so started uh writing both novels
but i also write journalism as well
so when i left the white house i went to
i lived in turkey for a number of years
where i covered the syrian civil war
uh for places like the new yorker
esquire magazine
and i've been in and out of iraq uh as
well as a journalist
uh and so oftentimes you know i write
and i write novels and often my novels
are
are informed by the experiences that
i've had
uh who were you in high school about if
i'm in 10th grade with you who was
elliot ackerman in high school
you know what it's funny that you would
ask that so
i was not the upstanding citizen you see
before you today i was a
slacker skater kid kind of squeaking by
with you know high c's low b's
they don't like school that much um
foes always actually sort of are kind of
artistically inclined interesting
funny is so the people you know people
who see me say like isn't that odd you
had this military career and then you
wound up in the arts as a writer
the people who've known me the longest
will say
it makes sense to us that you're a
writer we always thought it was kind of
weird that you ran off and joined the
marines for eight years
so listen i think all of us right like
you know the poet walt whitman says we
contain multitudes
so we all have you know different parts
of our personalities that we're engaging
during different chapters of our life
so um so as a writer i kind of you know
engage in the arts
more than you know the parts of my
personality that were more
organizational
that i engaged in when i was in the
military so did you always know you were
going to be in the military or
if you didn't what was the tipping point
when you said i'm going to go join the
marines
yeah i always suspected like so i was i
grew up abroad so i spent
i was born in los angeles i moved to
london when i was nine years old
and just just even me in london like i
think that gave me an appreciation for
what it means to be an american kind of
how our society is a little bit
different
um that made me want to serve um you
know i wanted a job when i got out of
college
uh where i'd have a lot of
responsibility and uh you know the
marine corps certainly gives you that i
can't think anywhere else where you know
22 years old they put you in charge of
45 people
um you know and i was also that kid who
like never stopped playing with his gi
joes
so you kind of combine all that together
and it leads me to go off and join the
military was the admiration there of
your father for you to want to be a
writer as well
or was it something that you just
you had the creative side where
eventually you were going to end up
writing and maybe one of your siblings
didn't
well then said listen i would first tell
you like you know when you just when i
first started writing
uh you know i was doing it very quietly
like i had another job
kind of you know i carved out time to do
each day because
at first saying you know i want to be a
writer like it sounds kind of silly
right it's like saying you know
i want to dance you know like it seems
like no one's going to take you
seriously you have nothing to show for
it so um
so i did it quietly and then i uh you
know i started demonstrating some
success and
i was able to kind of transition into
that career what's cool is both you and
your wife are writers right
yes yeah my wife screenwriter and i and
a very
and a great novelist yeah and she what
was the screenplay she did with um uh
mark wahlberg right with the mile 22 i
think if i'm if i'm not mistaken
oh you're right yeah she uh she wrote
the screenplay for uh his film
uh mile 22 which was directed by uh pete
burke
i mean that's respect so both of you are
you guys always collaborating so babe
what do you think about this what do you
think about that here's the character
does this visual do you can you see this
does this look realistic or is it just
independently
not telling each other what you're
working on no i know what she's working
on um we work very differently
you know i i'm so she reads all my stuff
she's like
typically my first reader when i finish
a book or if i'm working on stuff
uh but we work differently in that you
know when i approach my work
i'm very much i guess it's the marine in
me i sit down on my desk every day and i
know what i'm gonna do and i'm gonna
write my thousand words today
whether i gotta like put my head through
the computer screen to do it
and she will be kind of you know she's
very brilliant like she'll be walking
around
looking like she's you know cooking or
doing something around the house
and she won't seem like she's working
for days or sometimes even weeks and
then she'll sit down and she'll write
you know
40 pages in a burst and i and for her
it's like she's working it out in her
head for a long time so we
we work in different ways very cool okay
so let's talk about by the way that's
what you call
power couple within the same industry i
mean you know god knows what the upside
is with that and what kind of projects
you guys are going to come up with
let alone with the kind of a resume you
already have so future looks bright
for the acremen and the carpenter family
so let's
let's talk about 2034 a novel
of the next world war can you
paint a picture of what the story of
2034 is where
uh the viewer who hasn't read your book
or doesn't know much about it what the
premise of the book is
yeah absolutely well listen the purpose
of the book is that the novel imagines
what it would look like if the united
states and china went to war
primarily at sea in the aforementioned
year
so maybe let me let me give you kind of
a quick tour of the books first if
someone hasn't read us you'll know
what's going on so
when the book opens there's five primary
characters so when the book opens you
meet the first one and that is commodore
sarah hunt
and you see here on the bridge of her
destroyer and she is on what's called
the freedom of navigation patrol
these are patrols we run the south china
sea today because the chinese claim the
entire south china sea is territorial
waters
it's a body of water that's half the
size that continental united states
so we see her on one of these patrols
and she spies a
what looks like a fishing trawler on
fire in the south china sea she goes to
investigate when she gets there she
realizes that it's anything but
a run of the mill fishing trawler on
fire then we cut to the other
side of the world you meet the second
principal character and that is marine
major chris wedge mitchell his call sign
is wedge because a wedge is the world's
oldest and simplest tool
and he's flying his state-of-the-art
f-35 joint strike fighter above the
straits of hormuz
when the controls of that plane
literally stop responding to him and the
aircraft diverts into iranian airspace
on a glide path down to bonder boss
airfield
i cut to the white house and you meet
the third principal character of the
five
which is dr sandy chowdhury
he is a first generation indian american
and he is the deputy national security
adviser at the white house and as he's
trying to make sense of these two crises
that are all
unfolding the one in the south china sea
and the one above the straits of hormuz
his telephone rings and the other end of
the line is the fourth principle
character of the book
admiral lin bao and he is the chinese
military attack shape the united states
and he has a message
for sandy chowdhury which is that those
two events are not unrelated and the
chinese
are sick and tired of the us sending
these freedom navigation patrols into
the south china
sea the south china sea is there is
their territory
at which time there's a massive cyber
attack on the united states
basically the lights go out and they
come back on you know the whole eastern
seaboard is basically
blinked and that's basically the end of
the first chapter of the book
and i mentioned there are five
characters the fifth you meet at the
beginning of the second chapter
and that is brigadier general costume
farshod
a veteran of the iranian kudz force
a consummate uh forever warrior he'd
fought in places like iraq afghanistan
syria places where i fought but on the
opposite side
and when wedge lands on that airfield
the guy who's waiting to interrogate him
is far shot so you meet these five
characters and really through their
eyes you enter the world of 2034
you know in which we're seeing all of
these nations march off uh
into a cataclysmic war so when you're
coming up with these characters how many
of these characters are
uh people in your life that you've met
how many of them are people that
at some point there was like some
soleimani like is it a comparison to
like the general of there or you know
how many of them are real characters
that you're kind of uh
because the book is a fiction book but
it also seems extremely realistic
you know what i mean it's not like
you're reading a fiction you're kind of
looking at the saying
this is kind of believable you know when
you're writing a book like this so how
much of your creative mind was
somebody you met or somebody that's in
the market today as a leader
well mike you said my creative my
creative mind is like an associative
mind right so when i'm sitting there i'm
you know
trying to build these characters you
know i'm pulling in all sorts of
you know all sorts of stuff like things
that have happened to me oh wedge
he's sort of maybe he reminds me of this
guy i once met you know on the uss iwo
jima and
you know casting far shot he's like this
one general i met like you know for
instance
he's described as his hand his right
hand he's missing two fingers so he sort
of has this claw
there's actually a very famous marine
corps general uh who was just
this guy was a vietnam vet tough as
nails he actually had the
world push-up uh record at one point and
he had his hand was like that he had two
fingers blown off from vietnam
and i just said like that's just like a
detail because i was thinking of like
you know what's farshad like he's
probably like this general a little bit
and i remember that guy's hand and how
that just sort of was you know he could
choke you to death with these three
fingers and i
you know you want to compare that so
it's all these little things that's kind
of
bringing together to try to make the
character feel real so that you can see
that character as a reader
so right here while i'm looking at the
screen on this side what i did is i
pulled up
evolution of wars right like how we've
gone to war evolution of it so it starts
off with saying
you know phase one you know bayonets we
got muskets
we got uh you know cannons mortars
then you got the naval ships showed up
and you got machine guns flame throwers
poison gas
aircraft tanks atomic bomb
it's just kind of talking about the
evolution which is what we've kind of
gone through
recently you've been hearing a lot about
how
you know uh uh us historically oh we
spent so much money on military but we
keep buying the same stuff that we went
to war with maybe 20 years ago 30 years
ago versus
you got a china that they spend more
money on cyber warfare you know bio
warfare a lot of different kind of
direction they're taking versus the way
u.s is spending that their resources
how different of a war is 2034 going to
be
than what we expect is it anything
out of the ordinary in your mind
imagination in your mind that you say
these are a couple things that's going
to happen that nobody's probably paying
attention to today
i think it's important to point out like
2034 is a
cautionary tale it's not a predictive of
course in so much as
we're not trying to predict the exact
technology but we're trying to show like
this these are the trends and you hit
the evolution of war so the one thing
you always see
is that you know one technology kind of
overtakes another technology and so
often times
you know as americans we're sitting here
and we're constantly trying to like
refine our technology we're spending all
this money on new aircraft carriers and
on new jets
uh and fighter planes but we're not
asking ourselves the questions like is
this the right technology
to be investing in and you see that in
2034 there's a massive cyber attack at
the beginning of the book and what that
cyber attack does is
it acts as a level a leveler so suddenly
all these
very high-tech platforms we have they
don't work
like you can't turn them on so without
spoiling anything in the book i would
tell you like when you meet wedge right
he is flying this state state-of-the-art
f-35 joint strike fighter that doesn't
work
the last time you see wedge he is
piloting a generation one
f-18 hornet built like circa 1990
uh on his final mission that's got no
technology in it and so
thematically one of the the issues the
book wrestles with is
how does technology work in a war how do
we advan take advantage of technologies
and then have to sometimes
use all technologies to outsmart our
adversary
essentially are you saying that the
modern technology is easier to hack into
and tap into than the old technology
yeah it is and sometimes the way you
defeat technology is without technology
can i give you an historical example
yeah
so like um i'm a history book one of the
one of my favorite battles i've studied
is the battle of agincourt
which was fought in 1415 it was made
famous by william shakespeare in the
play henry v
and at that battle basically a british
force had invaded france they were at
the end of their supply lines
uh ill-equipped trying to get back to
england
strung out when the entire french army
assembled against them this is like the
cream of the french
medieval nobility and they were decked
out on the battlefield of agincourt the
french
with what was the most state-of-the-art
technology at the time
and that technology was plate armor
they figured out how to fold steel into
plates to make these knights like
unstoppable so the french knights come
out there with their ex very expensive
technologically state-of-the-art plate
armor it rains the night before on that
field
and they're gonna go destroy this
ill-equipped smaller english army
they go and charge across this field and
they kind of get bogged down in the mud
because they're
their armor so damn heavy and the friend
and the english have a totally different
technology that is
far less far less expensive and that's
the longbow
and they shower down arrows on the
french knights and just slaughter them
it's one of the greatest french military
defeats of all time
that is an example of yeah you might
have the most state-of-the-art
technology
in your plate armor or in your f-35
or your ford class aircraft carrier but
it's the wrong technology for the battle
you're about to fight
what what okay so let's let's play on
that because again
yes it's fiction what you're writing but
let's face it you're not
like a guy who went to school and read
all the books and then you write books
about military and war so yeah you know
i just went to school i read all these
books my dad was a
veteran but i just i'm fascinated by
writing no no you were in there
you you got you're decorated you know
you got stuff that you have bronze star
for valor
purple heart silver star you know
special ops i mean you've gone to the
you know what is the special ops of
marines i know in the army
it's a delta force what is special ops
yeah i was a marine raider okay got it
so so when you go at that point
you have to know you have some moral
authority and i'm assuming your friends
are probably within the same community
that maybe you know you don't disclose
who the friends are and people that you
talk to each other with
what direction do you think we are going
right now one of the things i researched
the other day which
i couldn't believe was how many military
bases u.s
has in different countries and how many
military bases china has
china u.s has some 800 military bases
that we pay
in 70 plus countries china has
one military base and that's that's the
choke point of the suez canal
they don't have that many military so i
sit there and i look at the cost i'm
like why are we spending so much money
trying to save everybody's marriage
why are we spending so much money trying
to be hero to everybody and we end up
being a bad guy anyways because
anytime you're too involved in someone's
marriage of trying to save it what
typically happens at the end
you're the bad guy right you're like oh
my gosh she was too much involved versus
china saying look instead of spending
all this money here
we're going to keep getting stronger and
stronger and stronger and stronger and
stronger from the outside
many will say china hasn't yet passed
u.s up in having the strongest military
navy they have we saw the stats about a
month ago
how they have more ships now than we
have and ours are old those are more
advanced and there are missing money in
naval ships
to protect the southern part which is
what you're talking about what is your
biggest concern with china long term
well i think you know my concern um you
know it's something you know if you
if you get into the book you'll sort of
see manifest in the scenario is that
we're preparing for the wrong type of
war
and because there there's so much
momentum
in terms of uh the way we invest in
certain platforms and even how we
as americans imagine war uh it becomes
very difficult for us to think about it
in new ways and we need to be thinking
about it in new ways now
people are trying to do this you know my
own service the more you know the marine
corps is actually doing a pretty good
job of this right now
they just got rid of all the tanks that
used to exist in the marine corps like
we're not gonna
marines aren't gonna be if we're
fighting in the south china sea we're
not gonna be using tanks and they're
trying to think about what like a
21st century island hopping campaign
might look like if they you know if we
needed to fight that fight
but it's very very difficult because
there is just so much
inertia that exists in the platforms
we're invested in
our force posturing as you alluded to
and just
in our our thought um so i think you
know to me that's the ideas you know
what if we're
preparing uh for the wrong war uh and i
think
i think those are you know those are
questions that we need to be you know
engaged with right now and some people
are you know the characters you have in
your book sarah hunt you got
chris wedge mitchell who's the one
that's flying the f35e
you have uh uh uh main countries you're
touching up on which is china
iran russia india
you know india is one nation that china
doesn't like a lot they like to mock
them
a lot you know and they're kind of going
back and forth and india's
got a younger crowd china's a little bit
older they just increase the amount of
babies a family can have because they're
starting to realize they're getting
older
so indirectly they try to mock india but
they're worried about india because
india india's not playing the games of
oh let tick tock and let this and let
that and then he's like no you can't
come in here modi kind of standing up a
little bit to them
and then you have china who's bought
iran they just signed a 25 your 400
billion out of contract so you know kind
of that thing
that's taking place and russia's always
going to be in the picture with the um
having the most nuclear you know
warheads i think there are ten thousand
three or whatever their numbers they're
above everybody else
uh who what role are these guys gonna be
playing
in your book in your book let's play in
the role that they're going to be
playing because you
highlight a lot of different uh
arrogance and miscalculations
all nations make you're not just kind of
one of those books where you read where
america sucks you know they have no clue
what they're doing they've lost their
edge no you're kind of calling it out in
every possible way again
it is fiction it's not a prediction
you're playing with ideas right but
there's a part of it that's
possible what roles in your book
do you see can you tell us so the
audience can know
u.s place their miscalculations china
russia and india just to give us a
glimpse not enough
we don't want to read the book but
enough for us to kind of get an idea
well i'll say listen the spirit of this
book is like there's no
mustache twirling like villain in this
book
you know we want to make real characters
you know i want these characters to feel
real to you
so each of these characters you know
when they step onto the page and you're
reading
you know the sections that are told from
their point of the point of view you
know they're stepping onto that they're
on that page is that they're on a stage
and they're making their case to you the
reader as though you are god like this
is the world according to them
and so i think for like you know a guy
like sandy chowdery who's working in the
national security council
you know he has he he's concerned about
many issues that you know we were just
talking
about which is you know there is a story
that america has been telling itself
for generations now and is that story
really true
or are we you know are we
kidding ourselves and and and deluding
ourselves
as to the preeminent position we hold of
leadership in the world and he
wrestles with that and i you know i
wrestle with that i don't have answers
but those questions are framed
throughout the book so you know for
america it's sort of this idea of you
know how do we
you know how do we keep on being america
and does the you know the one thing that
makes america unique as a nation it's
like we're not a blood and soil nation
you know you can't you know i couldn't
immigrate to china and become chinese
you know you're chinese you can come the
united states you become you assist and
you're you know you're
you know you're american so that's how
it works and so that's unique and what
is
and how does that idea fit into the long
arc of the world how does a
society that is like ours
that is 245 years old based around this
idea
or really ideal set of ideals compared
to a country like china that's
thousands of years old and has a very
different sense of itself and when you
get to the chinese character lim bao i
mean you know lim bao
is a guy who um has an interesting cache
in china and so much is he's a military
attache
but he is of split american chinese
parentage his mother was american he's
raised in china
and so within the chinese regime this
makes him you know
someone who is very appealing because he
you know he's able to understand the
american psyche he's a
naval war college um but he's distrusted
by the chinese as well so he sort of is
in this in between space and he can
understand
both arguments and he's frustrated by
what he perceives as american hubris
but he also sees some of the you know
china's not 10 feet tall he sees you
know you mentioned the demographic
weaknesses in china
uh difficulties they have with
transparency that you see playing out in
the book and that we've just seen with
kovid
i mean you know listen like you know
china gave us the virus
the free world right now is giving us
the vaccines and i think everyone should
pause
and remember that with the year we've
gone through as we think about the role
of china
then you have farshad you know with iran
you know what is the role of iran uh in
this you know
you know a country that is you know in
the middle east trying to figure out its
sense of itself
who it should be allied with you see
many shifting alliances as you alluded
to
and then we get to you know to russia i
mean the role of russia in this book and
oftentimes is just sort of
as the joker you know they know that
they are the strongest when everybody
else is the weakest
so they don't want to see alliances and
they behave they
you know they they act out in ways that
frankly don't really serve
a larger strategic objective than just
kind of screwing things up for everyone
so they can
the way we win is we're the tallest
[ __ ] if anyone's taller than a [ __ ]
we don't we lose but if everybody's like
in a [ __ ] level we're the tallest
[ __ ] yeah that's makes
russia behaves in the book so is it
essentially like the
the typical uh behind closed doors never
commit to anybody 100 percent you know
indirectly create more proxy wars you
know
constantly stay out of it yet enough
inside where people need you create
opportunities where you're needed and
you come out the hero
but at the same time you know if anybody
wanted to face off against you directly
you would destroy them
and that's russia yeah right i mean
listen you know we talk about where the
where the
you know where parts of the book come
from you know no i think like one
i think a great uh piece of filmmaking
is um
the nolan's the dark knight in the
batman movie
and like russia's the joker in that
movie you know and that that scene where
he's talking about
the joker is talking about you know i
just want to throw a little chaos into
the mix you know i'm like a
i'm like a dog chasing a car i wouldn't
know what to do if i caught it
like there's a lot of that informing
russia
how russia behaves in this war they know
like they engage in behavior so they
know like we don't really know who this
is gonna benefit
we just know it's going to screw
everything up for everyone and that
that will help us let me let me ask you
a question so
part of what i'm asking you is your
opinion obviously at this point if the
reader wants to go and learn more about
you know how you're presenting the book
we're going to put the link below for
folks to be able to go buy it it became
an
instant new york time bestseller and you
ought to go read the book it's not like
it's being written by somebody that's a
fiction writer that doesn't have the
backing to
make it extremely realistic but from
your standpoint where you're currently
at
uh uh in your opinion who concerns you
the most i mean obviously
you know china's at the top where a lot
of people say it's china you got india
that comes up we just kind of figure out
how you're presenting russia to be what
should we be most worried about
again just a year ago we've never had a
shutdown in u.s
it's never been like hey you got a
shutdown for your california's barely
coming out of it
take the masks off they came back out
yesterday two days ago put the masks
back on oh no no you can take it off
we've never been through this what are
some other weird things like this that
could happen like what happens to
america and the world if a real
cyber attack actually took place what
does that look like what does life look
like with that can you
use a little bit of creativity to say
you know here's what concerns me
and if this does take place this is what
it will look like let me paint a picture
for you
yeah i mean well you asked you know kind
of who among all these state actors to
me is the most concerning
uh and my answer would be us i'm the
most concerned about actually the united
states
and our ability to come together as a
country
and respond coherently in the way we
have done throughout our history
when there is a challenge that presents
itself outside of our borders
and listen and um
you know i remember how in after
september 11th you know
the entire country came together like
this you know
very quickly and before the pandemic
and and i'm not saying this in any type
of person way i'm exhausted by all the
partisanship
but i'm just sit but i can tell you you
know many times sitting with friends at
dinner over a drink
pre-pandemic kind of wondering you know
as as our society just was keeping
getting more and more divided
like hey you know i wonder if there was
like a 9 11 type attack you know if
there was a real existential crisis in
the united states like we'd be able to
come together like we did in the days
after september 11th
and talking about that with friends like
the pandemic presented
that type of a crisis i mean there's 600
000 dead americans right now based off
this pandemic
and 2020 i think was is the most
divisive year we've had since 1968.
that does not bode well for the united
states the um
you know i'm being a little facetious
here but i've always said like you know
like the strength of the united states
like we're kind of like jazz hands
you know like we got all sorts of crazy
stuff going on like people are doing
this they're doing that you know
diverse million that's great and that's
a fantastic way to be
and you can only be diverse like this if
when the moment comes you can take your
jazz hands and you can put them into
fists when you need to
and if you can't put them in a fist
you're going to get punched right in the
nose
and what concerns me right now is this
cut you know the country
with you know just the the the division
that we see the fact that we
you know there's there's so few things
we all agree upon
um that the greatest threat pose the
united states
to me seems to be ourselves and our
inability to get our act together
you think it's gonna happen so okay so
let's go there so let's go a layer below
that
what's caused this divisiveness who's
who's dividing and what's the benefit to
them to divide
so many things i think you're just
seeing a perfect you know there's like a
perfect storm
uh i don't think you can say oh there's
like one cause
you know like oh you know i'm not gonna
say oh it's you know donald trump or oh
it's nancy pelosi or you know
no it's a perfect storm you know our
media you know i think listen the way
our media works right now
um you know where people are
incentivized to be extreme that's how
you get attention
attention gets you followers followers
get your money it gets you voters you
know i think that
that certainly plays into the
divisiveness if we look at how our
elections are run right now
you know with you know with our primary
system that kind of incentivizes people
who are out on the fringes
as well uh i think i think that is
that's a challenge you know the amount
of money that's in politics has been
been a challenge
demographic changed the united states
you know we're facing huge demographic
changes
that we have to figure out how to
navigate through that you know all these
things are happening
and you know they've happened before i
mean the united states has had to like
figure out how to be the united states
and constantly reinvent itself
um before but we're in one of those
moments right now and if we don't figure
it out like it's
you know it's it's not just a given that
we figure it out
how do you figure it out though i mean
you have to realize we have a lot of
smart people in this country right we
have
we have a lot of people when you when
you read the book there's a book
barbarians to bureaucrats the author
lawrence miller talks about the fact
that
every society organization company goes
through certain faces first you got the
prophet which is the founding fathers
like hey
here's an idea of america we're going to
go away from britain and this is what
we're going to do
then you got the barbarians these are
guys that are willing to go to war and
fight and do the dirty work they get the
scars
you know all this dirty things that
happens to them but they handle it
they're not afraid then you have the
builders and explorers which is the
industrial age
we build training build trains you know
hotels buildings all this stuff
then shows up the administrators the
lawmakers
then the bureaucrats then the
aristocrats and they screw the whole
thing up
we're in the bureaucrat and this
aristocrat phase right now
but it says in order to save it and
prevent this from happening
you need a synergist or a group of
synergies who is a synergist today
and does this climate give birth to a
synergist who would you call a synergist
today i mean
because when you're saying we got to
figure out a way to bring it together
we are hearing that but who can do that
today
is it even possible to do that today
i don't know i don't i mean i don't i
don't have i don't have an answer i
i agree you know i think there's a lot
of credence to the to the template that
you just laid out
uh laid out there uh and i think
you know the contribution i'm just
trying to make is to
is to call greater attention to those
types of arguments like that this is the
challenge of today
like it's you know if if someone's
telling you that this this one political
figure is the reason why
this individual is the reason why we're
having all these problems
uh i would say you know you're not
seeing the forest past the trees
i mean you know this there are bigger
things afoot so
i think the first step is just for
having your your thinking straight
on where we're at in this in this longer
cycle
um but i don't have one single
prescriptive thing we can do to cure
all of our societal ills at this moment
it's crazy like your answer you know
you said i don't know i'm just giving
out my perspective
and you know and let the you know
audience make a decision for themselves
there are so many uh people who are
decorated smart intellectual
resume moral authority to
who can do something about it i'm not
pinning it on you i'm just saying
there's many of us
that can do something about it but
there's almost
this and i i hope
call me out just trash my argument
whatever i say to you say pat i disagree
with you
there's almost this feeling of yeah
i know what's going to happen if i try
to play the synergist they're going to
trash me they're going to this no no you
do it
no no i think you should do it no no you
do it no you do it
i think you ought to do it i think you
i'm just giving you my perspective you
do it
there are so many people afraid right
now walking on eggshells
to go talk about that stuff because what
if you lose
your clout what if you seem like you are
too far left or too far right or too far
this or too far
i don't want to be put on the box you
know so it seems like a lot of
influencers who can do something about
it
feel like they're walking on eggshells
and they don't want to do anything
because their career may be won't what
do you think about that
i think it's certainly true listen i
don't count myself among those like i'm
writing books i'm writing columns
you know every day and i'm i'm saying
what i'm saying and if you don't like it
then
you know it's true you don't like it so
um
i don't feel like i myself am walking
necessarily on on eggshells but i feel
like yeah i feel like people are and
there's
there's definitely an intimidation game
that's going on
uh i i would certainly say that i think
you know
leadership helps i don't know that's you
know
waiting around for like one you know the
perfect presidential candidate who's
going to pull us out
all you know i i think that's you know i
think you're going to be waiting time
for that yeah
but i think listen i think cultural i
think they're you know
i'm hopeful that our culture will become
less less tolerant of
the you know censorious the the string
of sensoriousness that has kind of
sprung through it in which people are
trying to kill each other cancel each
other destroy each other's livelihoods
because of a difference of agreement i
think those people uh you know who
behave that way are no nothings
and uh and pariahs and you know we need
to be able to disagree with one another
and and move on
uh and for some reason we've gotten past
that so
uh i'll i'll sing that to the rooftops
you said uh uh we haven't been this
decisive i think you said since 1968. i
think that's the year you said 1968.
uh are you saying like post barry
goldwater the whole you know is that is
that kind of where you're going or 1968
which part of 1968 yeah yes civil rights
vietnam
uh i think this is in many ways worse
than 68 um because
unlike 68 you know you see our
institutions
are are right in the mix of all this
being torn apart you know
in the 60s you had a counter culture
movement and then you kind of had
our institutions able to still function
while there was this like you know
really divisive counterculture movement
going on um
and you know some elements of the
counterculture were absorbed into
institutions
and you know metabolized i think right
now what you're seeing
is uh you know the counterculture
has become the culture and uh there's
there's
there the in the institutions are
pulling in wildly different directions
and so there's like no there's no
there's no middle there's no center to
stand on anymore
yeah so so when you when you're talking
about that earlier you said
you know how uh if you think about a
person going from here to china
you know uh uh you don't become chinese
but if a chinese person comes over here
you can't become american i'm from iran
i lived there 10 years i lived in
germany two years
i'm armenian a syrian born in iran but i
came here i consider myself an american
today right
so did
did america lose its core culture and
ideals
by trying to make it so inclusive by
letting everybody in here where we
lost our fabric what this was founded on
because everybody's like i don't agree i
don't agree i don't agree
so they try to appease and try to please
everybody else that wants to change it
or and then
some of these countries that stayed core
today to their you know what they stand
for russia china india whatever maybe
they're like no this is what we're all
about you don't like it leave this place
versus america's like
oh you don't like it well let us change
for you do you think we've lost a little
bit of our
you know what we were founded on or no
again i think it's a little bit of a
perfect storm i think listen i think the
one one of the challenges that we face
is you know if you and i'm speaking now
really kind of about politics
i believe that you can define politics
in the fighting way you know politics
is the acquisition or maintenance power
can we agree that's like a general
overarching yep hire or maintain power
that's what politics is
so there's two ways to do that right you
can unite people
which i would argue like very difficult
to do to really just unite people um
like maybe obama did it in 2008 he
didn't do it in 2012 like you know i'm
just looking for recent examples
or you can do what most politicians do
is they divide people
and the way you divide people is
typically you say you see that group of
folks over there
they're the ones who are causing you the
problems they're the ones that you're
supposed to be
afraid of and i'm going to protect you
from them
that's the thing fear you know fear is
how we divide one another
and so i think so many americans now
are incited to fear and we have a
political class
that continues to incite people to fear
incite them to rage and play on these
emotions because those our emotions are
a way of
not only acquiring or maintaining
political power they are ways of
acquiring or maintaining cultural power
economic power fear fear fear fear
fear it's everywhere and it's killing us
and so
you know have we veered away i mean you
know
uh sure like are there are there people
right now in the united states who are
saying that the democrat the demographic
changes that are occurring in this
nation or a reason to be afraid
yeah of course and there are politicians
who are making a lot of hay out of that
and then i would argue there are
politicians on the other side who are
making
hay out of people coming here saying you
know you're never going to be accepted
by the united states our country is
fundamentally
and forever flawed with racism and it
doesn't work and it's horrible from its
founding
and that's just you know they're just
photographic negatives of the same image
inciting people to fear in order to
either acquire or maintain their power
so you just like you got to see the con
yeah like see the con and if you see the
con you don't play into it
so so the so then the question you know
how it is i mean if you want to do that
it's so easy to control a
an audience who is not you know they
don't spend their time studying the
different sides of the argument and the
history of what took place what
percentage of the country
reads books after they graduate from
school or college and say hey let me go
study more history instead of reading
romance novels or watching netflix
and i'm you know i just think there's a
certain level of naivete that we have
uh to think that the the average voter
is going to be able to
spend the additional time to get deeper
in these issues as a historian yourself
who you've read i can only imagine like
visually i went to your kitchen table
sitting to your dad
sitting and talking dad i bet you've had
some of the most incredible
conversations with your dad
and your family like i wonder like
thanksgiving must have been a
it must have been a pretty cool
thanksgiving center what do you think
obviously you do some sports all that
stuff
but there's depth in the conversations
right and you're historian you've read a
lot of different books
from your thoughts historically what has
been the dna
or what a synergist has looked like that
have brought us together
not the fear guy not the divine guy or
gal
from your and maybe you say i don't know
pat i i don't know if i can think of
anybody
but if there is a dna of somebody that
you've seen say the audience is
listening to this and we have a lot of
different types of audience that listen
to this entrepreneurs investors
political people athletes those who
watch our kind of content that we have
what has been the dna of somebody that's
brought america together
that's and it's a really interesting
question um
you know i think you can't understand
the united states as it exists today
unless you understand the american civil
war
you know i'm endlessly fascinated by the
american civil war
because it's such a it's such a point of
departure
from what the country was before to what
it kind of becomes after it
and i think that when you study and you
know as i've studied and like learned
about the civil war
um the thing that kind of strikes me
time and again
is you know lincoln's like vision of the
country is a really it's a
radical vision just in so much as it's
it's a departure in many many ways of
what many people viewed the country as
pre-civil war
um you know if you look at the primary
historical test before the civil war
the united states uh are always referred
to as these united states
right like they're plural the united you
know these united states are these
united states
and then it becomes after civil war the
united states singular
uh and that is sort of a radically
different vision of what this country
was from its founding
so you know when he's sitting there in
like 1861 and 1862
and the r you know the the union army's
getting the snot beaten out of it by the
confederacy and things aren't looking
too great
you know the fact that he kind of holds
that course i think is you know it's
it's remarkable
and uh and there are many moments if you
want to play the alternate historian or
you can go into the civil war and see
how you know maybe that one breaks
differently
and you know the south is able to secede
from the union and we have a totally
different country so
for someone who like brings that brings
the nation together in the way that he's
able to do it
there was there was no trend he was sort
of following i mean he
had the vision and you know against a
lot of very difficult odds
was kind of crap it was you know weaving
out of whole cloth
what this country was kind of kind of
wind up being in the 20th century
that's what they consider him possibly
the greatest of all time yeah okay
whatever they show guy and and by the
way he doesn't come across as a weak guy
he doesn't come across as guys let's
just get along
can we all just listen to barney and you
know love each other and
i don't see him as a guy like that i see
him as a firm guy that could stand up to
opposition but still was able to
you know make a case for his argument
and still unite
and not compromise certain set of values
and principles
the question becomes is the current
marketplace set up for something like
that to happen while we have so many
enemies who are happy to see us
divided versus united that's the
question
yeah and again i think it comes a little
bit into like you got to be able to
recognize the con as it's happening
you know like you know one of one of the
great challenges we face right now is
that our adversaries
understand how they can leverage
information news and really just
divisiveness
into the u.s system to basically turn us
all inward on one another so we can't
pay attention
that's happening outside of our borders
so i was in aruba the other uh
last yesterday i just i took a couple
hundred my guys to rob we're having a
good time we're having a conversation
one at night
and i said you know what's one of the
biggest problems with america right now
they said what i said
i said you ever had a very bad fight
with your wife or your husband that if
people
saw it like it would be pretty
embarrassing yeah
i said if your worst top 10 worst fights
were public
and somebody didn't like you could they
figure out a way to divide your marriage
even more
of course how would they use it do you
think there's an ex or a brother-in-law
or a cousin or somebody or a friend
that's jealous and envious
that would love to see you guys get a
divorce yeah i said the last thousand
fights america has had with its husband
and wife
has been on facebook live that's what
america's been doing
america has their fights on facebook
live in china and iran and everybody's
watching us saying look at these idiots
telling us exactly their marital issues
let's divide them even more um but it's
it's part of the system that we have in
u.s we are very easily tearing
telling say you got the left and the
right put a husband and wife one of them
is a husband one of them is a wife
whatever just left wing right wing right
let's just look it as a wing
oh i from china from iran if russia i'm
sitting there saying
get these fools they just gave us the
next 38 moves
look at these guys we know how to
control those guys give them this
that guy's broke give him money that
guy's driven by power give him power
that guy's driven by this did you see
what he said about him go disclose what
he said more about them oh wow we found
more go get a couple hackers working on
this
um and by the way i don't know if that's
going to change
because the system it's it's a
systematic thing what are you going to
change that's the approach of free press
free debate free this free that so
everybody can see our problems that
we're having against each other what are
your thoughts on that
i agree i think that cycle you know
psychologically i think for many you
know many americans who are not
who are not staunch partisans one way or
the other which oh by the way is the you
know the plurality of americans the
united states
right now and the whole 40 identifies
political independence you know they
don't identify with either party
so for all of those americans i think
psychologically you know we're living
the equivalent of being like the
children
in some household where the horrible
household where the parents are like
crazy abusive to each other and refuse
to divorce
and so like every day we come home and
they're screaming and you know dad's
telling you like your mom is that's what
the
mom's saying the dad said and it's you
know psychologically and
it's you know it's it's very very
jarring and american political life kind
of is you know the equivalent right now
of you know
hatfields versus mccoys or capulets
versus montagues and
you know if you look at that play like
you know capulets and monkeys that's you
know romeo and juliet
the last line of romeo and juliet uh the
shakespeare writes uttered by you know
the prince
um the prince says uh see what a scourge
kills your loves with hate and then he
says
all are punished and then he screams it
again all
are punished and i feel like that's
that's going to be our epigraph when we
finish this kind of person warfare like
all are punished you think someone's
going to win worse
no one wins oh of course we're revealing
all of it to the world and we
yeah i give an idea this morning we're
doing podcasts and that's what i was
going to show you
i'm sitting there i have a story novak
djokovic says he might refuse to be
vaccinated against the coronavirus
because the world's number one as
opposed to vaccinations
okay and you just want his 20th one 20th
grand slam not our years ago
argument maybe the greatest of usa today
he's the greatest of all time better
than federer better than sampras better
all this stuff
i can't tell that story on youtube you
know why
i read the story of beasley a couple
weeks ago where beasley said why he's
not
taking you know gonna do force
vaccination whatever that's his opinion
i just read on twitter we got a strike
for
so the point i'm trying to make to you
is it is a form of
gatsad i had him on last week he said
it's a form of self-censorship
where you sit there and you're like it's
better i don't say nothing right now
because there's consequences
behind it right so the the
as much as i want to believe a synergist
can come out and do it but that
synergist has to be able to go up
against the
major virtual governments that we have
to be able to say let me say my thoughts
you don't like it let ten thousand
comments underneath it disagree with me
let somebody create a reaction video
saying patrick's content is trash i
don't agree with what he says about
capitalism or money or business and i
let people make a decision for
themselves
rather than nope you can't even say let
me silence you so
it it it makes it tough for synergists
to be born
in a silenced environment and a
democracy can only exist when there
is a free marketplace of ideas and
you know and and a a general ability to
understand on a certain set of facts
like listen like you don't have a buyer
you know
covered vaccines like i i think it's
totally it's totally reasonable if you
have a vaccine where all the data
is that exists is this doesn't affect
young kids and someone's gonna tell you
you gotta get you know
we're gonna get your like eight-year-old
a vaccine and it doesn't affect them and
these vaccines haven't been approved by
the fda that someone would pause and say
you know what like i'm gonna take a beat
maybe i don't want to do that for my
child
like that seems reasonable and we should
be able to
debate that and people should be able to
make a choice on that but
what you know what we're seeing right
now is the politicization of
everything that shouldn't be a political
stance
the you know the way countries become
deeply dysfunctional
is when politics seeps into every crepiz
of your life
so everything you do has a political
bodies and you cannot be free
of politics at all it's very hideous and
we're there i can't i mean i can't think
of anything
that doesn't have some type of political
bias in the united states right now
you got sports politics movies
politics hollywood video games
everything you do is like can i just
tell you like i'm a laker fan
i'm not i listen i just i don't watch
your skin i just look at the fact that
you're fun to play and
i enjoy watching you so a lot of it is
becoming that way
again uh uh whoever whoever is going to
play the role of a synergist i don't
think it's going to be one i think it's
going to be a lot of them
it's going to take a lot of courage it's
going to take a lot of wisdom it's going
to take a lot of tolerance it's going to
take a lot of understanding
to be able to go through it and there
have to be a way to unify yet stand up
to the bullies
and where you address where the bullies
are trying to play the manipulative game
i don't think you're going to win
everybody over just like abraham
couldn't lincoln could have win
everybody over
but i think there's a group of people
that are sitting around saying can
somebody say something because i'm
confused who's right brenda cause
everything
is this argument you look in the past
you know you used to have like you know
the republican party for instance you
know for a long time kind of one of
their models was you know where the
party of you know small government
i'm wondering if you're going to see and
who knows who the the parties or the
leaders that come out and say you know
it's another word for
for small government or for small
politics because both
both parties right now for big politics
everybody's for big politics good
politics it's in your life everywhere
who's for small politics like i'm for
small politics so someone comes out here
for small politics like they've got my
support can you unpack small politics
that you should be able to live your
life not walking around thinking about
politics every single second of the day
my my seven-year-old you know my
eight-year-old kid
shouldn't be thinking about the politics
of his movies or his
tv ads or you know that like we should
just be
free to you're not free if you're
thinking about politics
all day every day and if you look at
societies that are dysfunctional
it's when they become completely every
facet of the society is politicized
societies that work everything is in
politics you're free to just live your
life
it's it's crazy you say that i had who's
the recent is it
the the recent the commander of space
force that was fired
low mire i don't know if i'm pronouncing
this matthew loma or lieutenant colonel
lomar who was just recently fired i had
him on
two weeks ago and i said to him i said
you know when i was in the army
i don't remember anybody talking about
politics i was just in the army i went
in
i got out i was like cool i mean we
watched war movies we talk
military we talk ike you know grand
you're studying patent you're studying
some of the wars and some guys were
deeply into it
but i don't remember like hey you're
this i don't like i can tell you
i was in the army for three years and
most people who joined the army are not
uh people who have money so it's i came
from a broken family so we didn't have a
lot my dad's a cashier at a 99 cent
store a middle eastern
so a lot of hispanics a lot of blacks a
lot of low income from you know places
i don't ever remember racism i tell you
i was there three years i don't once
remember
even that word coming up in three years
and i'm asking this guy's like oh no
it's a completely different ball game
today how much has this thing changed in
12 years so
again i like the small politics idea let
a soldier be a soldier let an athlete be
an athlete and
create criterias where we're not being
judged just because we're taking a
certain position here
it's if you're if you're a patriots fan
you're probably a republican you know
it's it's like becoming like i'm just a
patriots fan you know i'm just like
i like if you look you know if you like
tom brady you're probably yeah that's
what i'm saying so you know if you're
so rather than no i like tom brady
because the guy's got seven super bowl
rings and guys a freaking monster
running at 40 to 43 years old he ain't
scared of nobody in the guys super
competitive that's why i like the guy no
it's not why you like him
it's because this you know even flags
i'm in florida everybody has american
flag if you have american flag
you're on one side politically no just
kind of this country changed my life so
yes i'm grateful for america
so again i i agree with you on the small
politics side i'd be so curious to know
where these synergists are going to come
and what whoever is going to be able to
unite america in the next couple years
i mean this person is going to be
written about
talked about studied for centuries to
come
because of what we have going on right
now but it's going to have to be a very
very strong
character human being that's not afraid
that can relate that can communicate its
message and it can convert people over
i don't know who that's going to be but
i'm looking forward to seeing what that
person is going to be
eliot i've had a blast with you i hope
the audience have
it's like i almost feel like you and i
had a coffee together and the audience
got a chance to watch it we just had a
conversation together which is great
folks if you haven't ordered his book
yet i'm going to put the link below to
novel four of the next world war from
elliot acreman
former white house fellow and marines
sir five tours of duty in iraq
afghanistan where we see the silver star
bronze star for valor and purple heart
eliot thank you so much for your time
take care buddy
thanks for having me yep 2034 do you
believe it can you visualize that taking
place coming from a person with his kind
of a resume with india
iran china russia u.s and the kind of
you know mistakes they're going to make
with the miscalculations want to hear
your thoughts comment below and can we
have a synergist
with today's climate even though
everyone's being censored if you enjoy
this interview
you may also enjoy two other interviews
i did one of them is with general
spalding
who gave his presentation to the u.s
government
on what china's vision was he wrote a
book about it called stealth ward
stealth war six months ago he got fired
if you've not watched it click over he
got millions of views
the other one is with the former space
force lieutenant colonel commander
lo meyer who got fired recently he gives
his perspective of how much the
has changed in the last couple decades
if you want to hear about that click
here having said that
take care everybody bye-bye